cracking open tarmac demolishing roads
the earthquakes footprint measuring
seven on the Richter scale it struck
seven miles north of Alaska's largest
city Anchorage in Holmes it was a
scramble for safety for many so far no
deaths have been reported nor any
injuries we've been in communication
with the Alaska National Guard our
primary use of their assets are going to
be patient transport if we have medical
emergencies and moving emergency
response personnel to areas that we
can't get to via Road if necessary the
earthquake was reported yesterday
evening and picked up by seismometers
thousands of miles away there's more
aftershocks subsequently struck and a
tsunami warning was temporarily
triggered expect aftershocks
the average of a aftershock sequence to
a magnitude 7.0 the largest aftershock
the mean is 5.8 we've already had a five
point eight right so it's it looks like
it's a very average sort of aftershock
sequence they could still be something
larger that happens we people in
Anchorage should expect to be feeling
aftershocks most of today and and it's
actually from a lot longer time the
biggest earthquake man I've ever felt in
my life as well as damage to homes
thousands are without power and a
declaration of disaster has been
declared officials say it may be weeks
before full repairs can be made to those
parts significantly damaged Adele
Robinson Sky News